WITH OUR REGULARLY SCHEDULED
THIS IS PROFESSIONS A MEETING A
COUPLE OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS ONE
IS THAT SO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
WOMAN QUIRK SILVA.
WHO IS SERBIAN TODAY WELCOME
GOOD TO SEE YOU AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE ONE BILL ON CONSENT -- WE
WILL NOTICE AN ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM SO A WILL BE OPERATING AS
A SUB COMMITTEE NOW AND WILL
FIRST THEN GET TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS AB. TWO TWO EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY
SO SOMEONE.
VERY IF YOU WISH TO PRESENT OR
IF YOU'RE STILL WAITING FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WE CAN
PERHAPS GOING.
TO KNOW YOU'RE GOOD.
GOOD AGAIN THIS IS AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHEN YOU WERE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWO TO A CLARIFIES
THAT A FOOD BEVERAGE OR CAUSE
MEDIC THE CONTAINS THE CBD
DERIVED FROM INDUSTRIAL HIM
CANNOT BE PER.
PROHIBITED BASED SOLELY ON THE
FACT THAT IT CONTAINS HIM DERIVE
CB DEEP.
ALL FOOD SAFETY LAWS IN RETAIL
FOOD STANDARDS WOULD STILL APPLY
SLIMMY JUST MAKE THAT CLEAR.
ALL FOOD SAFETY LAWS IN RETAIL
FOOD STANDARDS WOULD STILL APPLY.
LET ME CLARIFY WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIM IS NOT
MARIJUANA.
THE CVT CAN BE EXTRACTED FROM
BOTH WHEN IT IS PRODUCED FROM
HIM THERE ARE NO CYCLE ACTIVE
AFFECTS.
THIS IS BECAUSE BY DEFINITION
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CONTAINS ONLY
THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT THC OR
LESS.
THC IS A PSYCHOACTIVE COMPONENT
IN MARIJUANA PRODUCTS.
AS A STATE WE ALREADY LEGALIZE
CANNABIS WOULD NOT WITHSTANDING
A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S ONGOING
STANCE THAT CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NON
INTOXICATING ALTERNATIVE WE ARE
LAGGING BEHIND?
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF HIM
CBD IS RAPIDLY EXPANDING WITH
OVER A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
ECONOMIC PRODUCTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
MANY CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
CURRENTLY PURCHASE HIM SEE
BEAUTY PRODUCTS THAT COFFEE
SHOPS GYMS AND WELLNESS STORES
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT IS
TECHNICALLY WAS NOT LEGAL.
SHOULD THE STATE CHOOSE NOT TO
CLARIFY THE HIM SEE BEAUTY
PRODUCTS ARE DEAL FOR SALE
CONCEPTION THESE JOBS IN THIS
BUSINESS WOULD BE LOST.
LAST WEEK IN THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE I ADDED URGENCY CLOSE
TO THIS BILL DUE TO THE CRITICAL
NEED TO CLARIFY THE STATE'S ROLE
IN ENFORCEMENT OF HIM CVD.
WE CANNOT LEAVE OUR CITIZENS
FARMERS AND BUSINESSES WITH
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER HIM
DRIVE CVD MAY CONTINUE TO BE
SOLD AND PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT OF TWO WOULD NOT
HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES HERE.
ON BEHALF OF THE HIP AND
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
GREAT THANK YOU UP TO TWO
MINUTES IN TOTAL PLEASE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARE MEMBERS
JIM GROSS WITH NIELSEN WORKS
MARIN BEHALF OF THE U. S. HEMP
ROUND TABLE.
THE US HEMP ROUNDTABLE
REPRESENTS -- ALL LEVELS OF
SUPPLY CHAIN -- OUT FOR HIM --
AS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SAD THIS
BILL IS CLARIFYING EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH RESPECT TO
THE LEGALITY OF THE C. B. D.
DERIVED FROM HIM WE DO FIND
OURSELVES IN A UNIQUE SITUATION.
GIVEN THAT -- CALIFORNIA DID
LEGALIZE CANNABIS UNDER PROP
SIXTY FOUR WHICH INCLUDED CD
DRIVE FROM CANNABIS -- THE GOAL
HERE IS -- TO LAMINATE THE CLOUD
THAT HANGS OVER THESE
MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTORS
RETAILERS ALL OF WHOM -- HAVE
BECOME VERY INVESTED IN THIS
BUSINESS AS HAVE -- THE
CONSUMERS OF CALIFORNIA AS YOU
KNOW THEY CAN OBTAIN IT OVER THE
INTERNET -- BUT WE HAVE A
GROWING -- CALIFORNIA BASED
BUSINESS THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO ADDRESS -- I CAN ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LEGAL ISSUES BUT I THINK THAT --
BOTH COMMITTEES HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB OF LAYING THAT OUT I DO WANT --
TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS OR HAVE
MISTER BERYL BRIEFLY ADDRESS
QUESTION IS COME UP WITH RESPECT
TO TESTING SO IF I CAN YIELD OF
A MINUTE OR SO TO MISTER BAY SO.
ON THE ISSUE OF TESTING OF HIM
THANK YOU.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROBERT WITH CALIFORNIA HIM
COUNCIL VOTE HIM IN A HIGH
ENERGETICS AND JUST TO ADDRESS
THE QUESTION THAT HE POSED
REGARDING TESTING CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT OF MAKING
WAY FOR HIM GROWTH.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND TO
STAY AHEAD OF AN INDUSTRY THAT
IS CURRENTLY EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND DUE
TO GROW BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
ONE POINT.
NINE MILLION DOLLARS SO IN
REGARDS TO TESTING ITSELF EIGHT
TWO IN ORDER TO GROW HAMPER READ.
A GROWER MUST REGISTER WITH THE
COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER THEY MUST
HAVE GPS COORDINATES ON WHERE
THAT CROPS TO BE GROWN AND
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO GROW.
A IN BEFORE THEY THEY ARE ABLE
TO HARVEST THAT CROP HAS TO BE
TESTED THEY HAVE TESTERS THE
COME OUT AND TEST THE CROP FOR
CERTAIN CONDITIONS IS
SPECIFICALLY THC. TO MAKE SURE
IT'S NOT MORE THAN POINT 3% THC
IF THAT CROP FAILS THAT TEST THE
CROP HAS THERE ARE PROVISIONS IN
STATE LAW THAT CROP MUST BE
DESTROYED IN THE PROPER MANNER.
AND WITHIN A CERTAIN TIME FRAME
THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS FIFTEEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES -- WE ARE STANDING
UNITED WITH THE HEMP INDUSTRY --
THIS IS A GROWING EMERGING
MARKET A LOT OF OUR OPERATORS
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OF OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THIS MAY
BRING VERTICALLY AS WERE
STRUGGLING.
TO MAINTAIN AT COMPETITION OR
STAY COMPETITIVE IN THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT RAN
TWELVE STATES ARE ALREADY --
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS ARE HAVE
DEVELOPED REGULATIONS AROUND THE
PRODUCTION OF HAMPTON HAVE DRIVE
PRODUCTS -- AND WE URGE
CALIFORNIA PLEASE DO THE SAME
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
INTO THE MICROPHONE IN NAME
AFFILIATION CONVERSED INTO SO.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF CAL
EXCUSE ME NOR CAL CANNABIS IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO NATURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFAN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADAM
REGULAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GIVE YOU CAN TANA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASIAN IN SUPPORT.
AT MANY LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WOULD SAYS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS SO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THIS TABLE UP HERE.
AND WILL ALSO PROVIDE YOU UP TO
THREE MINUTES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU CAN IF YOU CAN STATE YOUR
NAME INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO ANYWHERE FEEL FREE.
IF FOR AND I AM THE CHIEF --
DEVELOPMENTAL OFFICER FOR I NEED
SEEN WHICH IS A CANNABIS TESTING
LAB IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE REASON WHY I AM OPPOSING
THIS BILL -- IS BECAUSE AND
THERE ARE NO CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR I TESTING WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL
CONTAMINANTS SCREENING.
OF CVD PRODUCTS I USED THEIR IS
TESTING WHEN IT COMES TO THE CD
LEVELS IN THE THC LEVELS.
HOWEVER AND CBT IS CONSUMED IN
APPLIED IN THE EXACT SAME
FASHION AS THC PRODUCTS ARE
THERE APPLIED TOPICALLY CONSUMED
ORALLY OR THEIR INHALED OR
SMOKED -- CAN SIMPLE NEARLY.
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT THERE AT
THE SAME RISK -- OF TOXICITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LEVELS OF
CONTAMINATION AND SO THEY SHOULD
UNDERGO THE SAME LEVEL OF US
SCREENING AT THE THC PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL ONES ESPECIALLY
SPEAKING OPPOSITION.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME IT'S A GREAT FOR DO WISH TO
CLOSE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THIS DOES ENJOY AID TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- AND WE WILL
GET TO THAT -- ONCE WE ASSIST
STEPS TO QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A NOW
MOVE ON THEN -- TO ITEM NUMBER
STREET WHICH IS A. B. FOR
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS AT
TOO PRESENTING OUR AB FOR
SEVENTY SIX WHICH CREATES A TASK
FORCE THAT WILL STUDY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON HOW TO INTEGRATE FOREIGN
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS AND HOW TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
FOR FOREIGN PROFESSIONALS I WANT
TO START BY THINKING THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS THE REINTRODUCTION
OF AB EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES FOR THE LICENSOR
LICENSING.
AND REGULATION OF VARIOUS
PROFESSIONALS AND VOCATIONAL
LOCATIONS BY BOARDS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
HOWEVER SOME IMMIGRANTS HAVE
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE PROCESS
HAVING MULTIPLE BARRIERS.
IN TERMS OF PROCESS TIME IN TIME.
IN S. OF DEGREE -- EVALUATION
AND ACCEPTANCE OF FOREIGN
CREDENTIALS MY A BILL AB FOR
SEVENTY SIX CREATES A STARTING
POINT JUST A STARTING POINT. FOR
REMEDYING THIS ISSUES BY TAKING
REASONABLE STEPS TO IDENTIFY A
SOLUTION TO THESE BARRIERS --
THREE TASK FORCE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT I HAVE JUST A BIT
VIELE FROM CHIRLA THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING --
AGAIN MY NAME IS JOSEPH JULY
DIRECTOR OF POLICY NOW BECAUSE
HE WE CHIRLA POLLUTION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRONT
TO THE SING A. B..
FOUR SEVENTY SIX CALIFORNIAS
HOME -- APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS IN A CURRENT
TO THE PUBLIC INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE. 201659% OF THE
NEWLY ARRIVED IMMIGRANTS WERE
FROM ASIA I'M IN THE MAJORITY OF
THEM HAVE AT SOME SERVE ADVANCED
DEGREE.
FURTHER MORE THE MIGRATION
POLICY INSTITUTE FOUND THAT
NEARLY HALF OF IMMIGRANTS ADULTS
ARRIVING TO THE TO THE U. S.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN HAVE A
COLLEGE DEGREE -- AND HOWEVER
THERE IS NO IS.
REGULATORY PROCESS --
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DAN REEVALUATE
THEIR THEIR AT THE CREDENTIALS
FROM A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
I'M CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT STRIKE TO INTEGRATE
ASPIRIN CITIZENS INTO OUR STATE
BY PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME TO STOP LIFE FOR PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE.
AS WELL AS BUSINESSES LICENSE
THIS BILL SISTER CONTINUE
WITHOUT PROGRESS BY REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO CREATE A TASK FORCE TO STUDY
IN MY REPORT -- TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
INTEGRATE THIS IMMIGRANTS FOR
ALL THE RACES WHERE -- WE HAVE
PROPER SPONSORS OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IT WILL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NINE ANY WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEE NO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA THANK YOU -- LIKE
TO ASK THE AUTHOR WHICH WOULD
WHAT KIND OF PROFESSIONS AND AND
OUR ENVISIONED.
WELL I WOULD LIKE TO SEE ALL OF
CURRENTLY HAVE -- SOMEONE THAT
IS A MEDICAL DOCTOR -- IN MEXICO
AND IS HAVING A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME TRYING TO TRANSFER THAT --
THAT LICENSING -- FROM MEXICO
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT -- WE HAVE
CERTAIN CRITERIA WHICH IS GREAT
BUT THERE'S ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT WE
HAVE A NURSING SHORTAGE SO I'M
THINKING NURSES WOULD BE
SOMETHING -- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT.
CAN BE LOOKED AT TEACHERS WE HAD
A TEACHER SHORTAGE -- A FEW
PROBABLY ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
AND WE WERE.
TRANSFERRING TEACHERS FROM THE
PHILIPPINES FOR EXAMPLE AND SO
I'M LOOKING AT ALL THE
PROFESSIONS I'VE MET SO MANY --
IMMIGRANTS AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS NOT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
FOLKS THESE ARE ALL IMMIGRANTS
NOT JUST ON DOCUMENTED FOLKS BY
THEY ARE PROFESSIONALS IN THEIR
OWN COUNTRIES.
AND THEY COME HERE AND THEY CAN --
THE BARRIERS THAT WE PUT UPON
THEM -- IN PROFESSIONS THAT ARE
IN NEED AGAIN LIKE NURSING --
STOP THEM FROM JUST TRANSFERRING --
EASILY INTO OUR OUR SYSTEM AND
SAW THE HOPE IS TO LOOK THE TASK
FORCE TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW JUST A
VARIETY OF OTHER PROFESSIONS BUT
SPECIFICALLY.
RIGHT NOW IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S MANY
MORE THAT WE CAN LOOK AT AND YOU
KNOW CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE.
THOSE FOLKS CAN COME IN AND JUST
BE YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT TAKES
BUT MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
APPLY AS OPPOSED TO ALL OF THESE
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT.
SOME OF THEM HAVE TO START ALL
OVER AND GO TO SCHOOL YOU KNOW
FOR ANOTHER THREE FOUR YEARS AND
THEY'VE ALREADY.
COMPLETED THAT EDUCATION IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES AND
SO I'M HOPING TO LOOK AT A
SIMPLER SYSTEM INSTEAD OF
SENDING THEM ALL BACK TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE IF THE ANSWER IS.
GO BACK TO SCHOOL WITH AND WHY
DO THEY NEED US -- RIGHT THEY TO
START ALL OVER BY BUT THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES THAT I'M
LOOKING AT SPECIFICALLY LIKE I
SAID.
I HAVE A A DOCTOR WHO WHO HAS TO
GO THROUGH A WHOLE BUNCH OF
BARRIERS AND WITH THE NURSING
SHORTAGE I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THOSE --
FIELD SPECIFICALLY FOR NOW.
YOUR BILL ASKED FOR STUDY YES I
PASSED FORCED A TASK FORCE --
IT'S A TOSS WORDS.
AT THAT -- THOSE SECRETARY OF
BUSINESS AND CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AND AGENCY DOES ANY
ONE MEMBER APPOINTED BY THE PRO
TEM ANOTHER MMHM -- MEMBER
APPOINTED BY THE SPEAKER ONE
MEMBER OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REGENTS ONE MEMBER
FROM CAL STATE UNIVERSITY BOARD
OF TRUSTEES.
ANOTHER MEMBER FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD -- AND
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR'S FROM THAT THAT DIVERSE
REGION -- BUT JUST SO THAT YOU
KNOW IF IT'S A UC ISSUE THAN THE
UC CAN WEIGH IN ON IT IF IT'S A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISSUE THOUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS YOU CAN
WEIGH IN.
YOU KNOW IT'S SO THAT WE ARE ALL
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENT -- TYPES OF
PROFESSIONS AND SO THAT IF IN
FACT IS THE UC'S FOR EXAMPLE
THEN THEY CAN SAY WELL THIS IS
THE THE WAY WE CAN CUT.
THE RED TAPE SO.
I I I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL --
YESTERDAY WE HAD A HEARING AND
SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE MAKING
REFERENCE TO COME THE UNITED
STATES COME TO CALIFORNIA.
TRAINED ALREADY TO BE DOCTORS
AND MANY TIMES WE ASK THEM TO GO
BACK TO SQUARE ONE AND START ALL
OVER AGAIN.
SO I ALSO IS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA MEXICO I
KNOW THAT THIS IS A TOPIC THAT
IS MUCH DISCUSS.
SO I VERY MUCH -- SUPPORT THE
BILL AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NONE AT SOMEONE RUBIO IF YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS DOES ENJOY A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BUT WE'LL GET TO
THAT ONCE WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHEN MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS AB.
FOR TWENTY BY SOMEONE MEMBER
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT -- A
BEFORE.
TWENTY THE GOAL OF THIS BILLS TO
SIMPLY GIVE AUTHORIZATION TO THE
CENTER FOR MEDICINAL CANNABIS
RESEARCH. TO CONTINUE PERFORMING
NECESSARY RESEARCH ON THE
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE EFFECTS
APPEAR CAMPAñA AIDS.
AN ASSOCIATE -- COMPOUNDS.
THE BILL BROADENS THE SCOPE OF
RESEARCH AVAILABLE.
TO CMC ARE THAT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
THEM THE ABILITY TO CULTIVATE
THEIR OWN CANNABIS.
THIS PROGRAM IS TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING A CONDUCTING STUDIES
TO DETERMINE THE SAFETY AND
EFFICACY OF BOTH.
CANNABIS ISN'T THAT IT KIND OF
ANNOYS.
IT'S CRITICAL TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE CURRENT CODE.
TO ALLOW FOR THE SUCCESS.
OF THESE STUDIES IF WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THIS NEW AND
INNOVATIVE FIELD OF RESEARCH IN
OUR STATE.
THIS BILL PRESENTS RESEARCHERS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE HEALTH BENEFITS.
THAT CAN BE GAINED FROM THE
SUBSTANCE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
DOCTOR TOM WERE CAUGHT WHO IS --
CO DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
MEDICINAL CANNABIS RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME.
SO I THOUGHT I'D JUST GIVE YOU A
ONE OR TWO MINUTE BACKGROUND
REGARDING THE CMC ARE SO THE THE
CENTER FROM JUST THE CAMPUSES IS.
HOUSE DOWN AT UC SAN DIEGO -- WE
DATE BACK TO THE YEAR -- TWO
THOUSAND WHEN WE WERE
INCORPORATOR ARE CREATED THROUGH
LEGISLATION BY THE FORETHOUGHT
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY HERE
AFTER THE COMPASSIONATE USE ACT
PASSED -- THERE WAS A STRONG
DEMAND FOR HAVING BETTER
RESEARCH REGARDING THE POTENTIAL.
MEDICINAL BENEFITS ARE NOT OF
CANNABIS SO WE RECEIVED FUNDING
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND WE
CONDUCTED A NUMBER OF CLINICAL
TRIALS -- SEVEN LOOKING OUT
SMOKED CANNABIS WERE VAPORIZED.
AND OVER THE YEARS WE'VE
MAINTAINED -- PRETTY STRONG
RESEARCH PORTFOLIO FUNDED BY
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
FUNDED BY PHILANTHROPY AS WELL
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEEN
DOING SOME STUDIES ON IMPAIRED
DRIVNG AS WELL RELATED TO KIND
OF THIS.
THE REASON THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE WHAT WAS IN
VISION TWENTY YEARS AGO -- IS
NOT COMPLETELY COME TO FRUITION
WE ARE NOW TO PLACE WHERE THE
UNIVERSE MISSISSIPPI STILL IS
THE ONLY SOURCE OF PLANT
MATERIAL.
AND THEY OF FAIRLY LIMITED
RESOURCES IN TERMS OF CREATING
THE TYPES OF CANVAS THAT OUR
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY USING --
WHAT THE VARIOUS CONSTITUENTS OF
KIND OF A DOLLAR CBT AND TO SEE
THAT WE MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN --
THE D. A. AS ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
WOULD OPEN IT UP TO MORE
MANUFACTURERS -- BUT SINCE
AUGUST TWENTY SIXTEEN NONE HAVE
BEEN APPROVED OR EVEN HEARD
FEEDBACK.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO POSITION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE IN A
POSITION.
TO CULTIVATE CANNABIS THAT COULD
BE USEFUL FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES.
IN THIS CASE THE C. M. C. R. WE
ARE NOT CLASS SIZE EXPERTS SO WE
WOULD COLLABORATE WITH
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS UC DAVIS.
AND IDENTIFYING THE BEST METHOD
FOR GROWING CANNABIS -- THE
OTHER KEY ASPECT OF THIS OF THIS
BILL IS THAT IT BROADENS THE
SCOPE OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
SO IN ADDITION TO CANNABIS.
CANNABINOIDS LIKE C. V. D. MIGHT
BE USEFUL FOR CERTAIN CONDITIONS --
BUT CURRENTLY -- QUITE OFTEN THE
CVT YOU GET FROM DIED INCLUDES
TEACH YOU SO IF YOU WANT TO LOOK
AT AUTISM IN CHILDREN YOU MAY
NOT WANT TO GET THEM HIGH.
AND ARE GOOD SOURCES RIGHT NOW
OF CBT WITHOUT THE PSYCHOACTIVE
EFFECTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PEACEFUL FREE
TO COME TO MY PHONE NAME
INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF EASE
IN SUPPORT.
EDDIE FRANCO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME -- SEE NONE JUST --
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU MISTER
LACKEY WITH RESPECT TO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF TRACK AND TRACE
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT THIS.
BILL PROPOSAL WHICH FACTOR IN
THE ENFORCEMENT OF TRACK AND
TRACE.
YEAH I DON'T THINK IT HAS MUCH
IMPACT ON ON TRACK AND TRACE
BECAUSE OF THIS IS MORE FROM THE
RESEARCH ARM.
AND ALL THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS --
BE ABLE TO HAVE THE RIGHT KIND
OF PRODUCT SO THEY CAN.
GET THE RIGHT KIND OF RESULTS
FROM -- THE EXTRACTION
EVALUATION OF CBC'S AND THE A
PAIRING ASPECTS ALSO.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND SEE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE
COMES AT THIS TIME MR LACKEY DO
WISH TO CLOSE WE HAVE JUST REAL
QUICKLY I WANTED KNOWLEDGE TO
WORK THAT.
THESE RESEARCHERS OF US
SPEARHEADED IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS.
AND IT WILL PERMIT THE
RESEARCHERS TO CONTINUE WORKING
TOWARDS THAT PARTICULAR GOAL AND
I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE IT WILL --
ADDRESS THIS.
BILL WHEN WE INVEST UP JUST A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS AB FOR NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND WEBER -- AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WHICH
WOULD EXEMPT VETERANS FROM WHO
OWN A SERVICE BUSINESS FOR MANY
CITY COUNTY OR STATE BUSINESS
LICENSE FEE.
OF THIS EXEMPTION ALREADY EXIST
FOR VETERANS WHO MAKE AND SELL
THEIR OWN MERCHANDISE THIS BILL
SEEKS TO EXTEND THE WAIVER -- TO
VETERANS WHO PERFORM SERVICES
LIKE MY CONSTITUENT MISTER
SPENCER.
WHEN APPLYING FOR BUSINESS
LICENSE FEE WAIVER MRS SPENCER
WAS DENIED BECAUSE THE EXEMPTION
ONLY APPLIES TO TANGIBLE
MERCHANDISE?
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WILL EXPAND
THE BUSINESS LICENSE FEE WAIVER
TO EXEMPT THAT TRIMS WHO PERFORM
SERVICES.
THIS BILL WASN'T WILL NOT APPLY
TO PROFESSIONAL LICENSES WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB
FOUR NINE EIGHT AS WE EXPENSE OR
A VETERAN OF THE UNITED STATES
MARINE AND MUSICIAN.
LET ME ALSO SAY AS WE BEGAN THAT --
WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S SOME
CONCERN ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF
SERVICES AND WE'RE WORKING WITH --
IF FOR THE NEXT COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE SOME AMENDMENTS WORKING
WITH THOSE WHO AFFECTED BY IT SO
WE WILL WE ARE AMENABLE TO A
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SO THAT TO
DEFINE SERVICES BY THOSE WHO ARE
PRACTITIONERS.
WHO CAN BASICALLY LEAD US AND
GUIDE US IN THAT AREA WE'VE ALSO
APPLIED FOR A -- A AMENDMENTS
ALSO WE FILE FOR AN AMENDMENT
THAT IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO LIMITED TO PER -- TO SOLE
PROPRIETORS SO WOULD NOT BE
THOSE WHO ARE IN AND WILL NOT AN
APPLIED TO THOSE WHO ARE DOING
FRANCHISES AS WELL.
SO IT WILL BE A VERY NARAL ONLY
SCOPE BILL DEALING WITH SOLE
PROPRIETORS WE WILL BE DEFINING
WHAT SERVICES ARE ARE IN AND
WHAT SERVICES ARE OUT -- AS WE
GO TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE SOMEONE
TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT IN
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF VETERANS
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL IS NARAL ENOUGH
THAT IF COMP WHICH IS WHAT WE
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
OKAY THIS TIME I'D LIKE YOU TO
HEAR FROM MR SPENCER.
HI HELLO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN -- I'M
RICHARD SMITH SIR AND FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
FOR CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE FOR
ME AND FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
VETERANS -- I SERVED IN VIETNAM
AS A CREW CHIEF ON A HELICOPTER.
I AND EIGHT HUNDRED COMBAT
FLIGHT HOURS.
ICE HAVE A SERVICE CONNECTED
DISABILITY FOR PTSD I WORK AS A
MUSICIAN I'M CURRENTLY A
VOLUNTEER PANAS THAT THE VA --
IN SAN DIEGO AND I SERVE OTHER
VETERANS IN THIS CAPACITY ALSO
MY REQUEST FOR A CHANGE IN THIS
LOT PRINCIPALLY IS TO HELP OTHER
VETERANS IT MIGHT BE IN A
SIMILAR SITUATION.
AS TO MY OWN.
I'M A BANDLEADER IN MY BAND
PROVIDES ENTERTAINMENT TO NINE
DIFFERENT NURSING HOMES IN THE
SAN DIEGO AND SURROUNDING CITIES
THESE JOB PAY AS LITTLE AS
TWENTY DOLLARS PER PERSON.
THIS TRIGGERED THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO ASKING ME TO PAY A CITY.
BUSINESS FATE PLUS FEES AND
PENALTIES FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS THAT I WORKED IN SAN DIEGO --
THESE FEES AND PENALTIES
AMOUNTED TO ALL OF THE INCOME.
THAT I HAD FOR MY NURSING HOME
JOBS FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR.
THIS SEEMED PREPOSTEROUS TO ME
HAVE FOR LOOK FOR A AN EXEMPTION.
OF FOR THIS -- WAIVER.
AND CHECKING STATE LAW I FOUND
IT WAS IN FACT I WAS IN FACT
EXAM FROM PAYMENT OF ANY CITY
BUSINESS LICENSE TAX BECAUSE I'M
A VETERAN WHO'S VENDING A WHERE.
I IMMEDIATELY CONTACTED CITY OF
SAN DIEGO TREASURER'S OFFICE
WHICH TOLD ME TO BRING MY DD TWO
FOURTEEN AND AND THEY GRANT ME
THE WAIVER.
HOWEVER WHEN I GOT THERE I SPOKE
TO SOMEONE ELSE WHO REFUSED. TO
GRANT ME THE WAIVER EVEN THOUGH
I HAD CALLED.
SPECIFICALLY BEFORE I WENT THERE --
SO A DIFFERENT PERSON SAID THE
WAIVER DIDN'T APPLY BECAUSE I'M
PROVIDING A SERVICE AND NOT
SELLING TANGIBLE GOODS.
HOWEVER IN CHECKING THE
DEFINITION OF THE WORD WHERE
MERRIAM WEBSTER WHICH IS A MAJOR --
DEFINING DICTIONARY.
IT DEFINES THE WORD WHERE AS A
GOOD OR SERVICE.
THEREFORE I DIDN'T KNOW WHY THEY
DIDN'T GRANT ME THE WAIVER WHEN
I CALL THIS FACT TO THE
ATTENTION THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
THEY RE ENTERED BOTH.
VERBALLY AND IN A WRITTEN LETTER
WHEN I ASKED FOR THEIR RESPONSE
IN WRITING.
THAT THEY DO NOT GO BY THE
DEFINITION AND AGAIN STATED
SERVICES ARE NOT COVERED UNDER
THE LAW WITHOUT A FURTHER --
AMPLIFICATION OF WHAT THE REASON
WAS WHY THEY WOULDN'T COVER IT.
THE PURPOSE OF THE LOWEST ASSIST
VETERANS TO START SMALL
BUSINESSES TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES.
BUSINESSES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN INCREASINGLY AND CORD
INCLUDE SERVICES VERSUS ASSEMBLY --
SELLING A GOOD I MIGHT POINT OUT
THAT IF ONE IS IS -- DESIGNING
AND AND SELLING THEIR OWN
SOFTWARE SOFTWARE ALTHOUGH
ALWAYS ON A TANGIBLE MEDIUM
MEDIUM IT IS NOT THE SOFTWARE
ITSELF THAT IS BEING -- SOLD
PLUS PEOPLE.
I MEAN IT IS NOT THE TANGIBLE
MEDIUM THAT IS BEING SOLD BUT IT
IS THE PRODUCT IRONIC WHICH IS
INTANGIBLE SO.
BY THAT BEING INTANGIBLE THE
CITY'S COULD.
DENY VETERANS THE BENEFITS OF
CREATING AND SELLING THEIR OWN
SOFTWARE THE COMMISSION AND
WOULD YOU CARE TO WRAP UP.
YES HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE
APPARENT AMBIGUITY OF THE WORD
WHERE VETERANS PROVIDE SERVICES
ARE POTENTIALLY DENIED THIS
BENEFIT FOR THE SAKE OF ALL
VETERANS NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY
THE ISSUE.
I REQUEST THAT THE STATE STATUTE
SIXTEEN OO ONE POINT SEVEN BE
CLARIFIED. TO INCLUDE THE WORD
SERVICES AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE.
YOUR GIVING ME THE TIME TO
PRESENT THE ISSUE TO YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US HERE IN THE STATE'S
CAPITAL ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HE NOTICES OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM COULD
YOU MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN.
THANK YOU -- AB FOR ALL YOU.
WE FIT.
TOGETHER [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I THREW ME OFF THE HOOK.
SO I GUESS MY MY MY QUESTION IS
IS.
AYE AYE.
**** THAT YOU'RE GONNA TRY TO
NARROW THIS BUT I GUESS I WAS
WONDERING HOW BIG A PROBLEM THIS
IS IS IT JUST A SAN DIEGO
PROBLEM OR IS IT A STATE WIDE
ISSUE I HAD A SITUATION ONCE
WHERE A A JIM TRY TO TELL ME I
COULDN'T JUST.
NOT BE HAVE THAT JIM ANYMORE.
AND SO I FIX SELLOFF AND BUT
WHEN I DID I HEARD FROM ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE ABOUT TRYING TO
GET A GYM MEMBERSHIPS WHAT A
PROBLEM IT WAS.
HAVE YOU HEARD THE SAME ABOUT
WARES AND SERVICES.
IN DOING THIS OR IS THIS JUST AS
SMALL SAN DIEGO ISSUE WHERE THEY
APPRECIATE VETERANS SOMEBODY WHO
IS A REPRESENT OF OF CAL VETS
THAT I'M IN TOUCH WITH ALSO.
PAID A CITY LICENSE FOR HIS CITY
AND ESCONDIDO I BELIEVE.
AND NOBODY TOLD HIM THAT HE
COULD BE EXEMPT FROM THIS -- SO
IT IS A WIDER PROBLEM THAN JUST
SAN DIEGO IT'S A STATEWIDE
PROBLEM AND THERE WAS A SIMILAR
PASSED TO TO LIMIT TO ADD
SERVICES HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO SACRAMENTO
HAS A SPECIAL ALL IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
THAT ALLOWS HIM TO DO SERVICES.
THE FAMOUS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOWN.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AT ITS -- SO I CAME
OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT TENTH
PERSONAL I SUPPORT VETERANS AND
I THINK WE SHOULD GIVE THEM ALL
THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL FOR THEIR
SACRIFICE FOR COUNTRY.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER -- TWO WE DO
NEED TO KNOW THIS BILL DOWN I
THINK WE THAT WE NEED TO GIVE
CLEAR DIRECTION TO THE
LOCALITIES THAT ARE GONNA BE IN.
FOR MAKING A DECISION ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SO THAT
IT'S EASIER FOR THEM TO
INTERPRET AND SO I LOOKED
THROUGH.
SOME THE LANGUAGE AND YOU
ADDRESSED IT EARLIER IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS SO THIS BILL IS
IS A DOUBLE REFERRED OR THIS WAS
GOING VETERANS WE'RE GOING IS
GOING TO VETERANS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I JUST WILL BE
LOOKING FOR THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
SEE -- THAT IT GETS CLEAR
DIRECTION TO THE LOCAL LOCALS
WHO ARE GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTING
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AND WE CONTACTED THEM -- THE THE
ORGANIZATION STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY I THINK IT IS OR WHATEVER
IT'S CALLED.
AND AND SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
WEIGHING IN ON IT WE'RE WE'RE
ASKING FOR THEIR GUIDANCE THAT
TO AFFECT THE CITIES YEAH.
OKAY WHAT GETS TO THE FLOOR SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHECK AND IS
SPENCER AND DR WEBER FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD OF BEATING
CURRENTLY -- ACTUALLY HAVE A
DIRECT NUMBER SO IF YOU COULD
JUST POP FOR ONE MOMENT
COMMITTEE SECRETARY.
OF MEMBERS.
LOW HERE BRO.
BLOOM.
CHEN JILL CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FONG GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA.
TING.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE NOW
STATUS CORM SO THE BILL -- THE
MOTION AND A SECOND PRETTY SICK
VERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY EIGHTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT TO
PASS A COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BRO I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
I EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG.
FUNG AT GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING. ELEVEN
VOTES EMILY THROW OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTOR WEBER.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
WHICH IS AB SEVEN ONE FOUR BY
DOCTOR WOULD.
DOCTOR WOULD THIS DOES ENJOY A
IN.
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
PLEASE PRESENT WITH EVERYBODY.
I'LL BE BRAVE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT.
EIGHTY SEVEN FOURTEEN IS THE
FOLLOW UP BUILT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY OF LAST YEAR THE REQUIRE
PRESCRIBERS JUST. TO OFFER
CERTAIN AT RISK PATIENTS WITH CO
PRESCRIPTION OF NALOXONE OR IN
OTHER FDA APPROVED OPIOID
OVERDOSE REVERSAL DRUG WHEN
OFFERING AN OPIOID OR
BENZODIAZEPINE PRESCRIPTION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES SOME
POINTS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS BY RACE BY PRESCRIBERS
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY PRESCRIBES A RAISE
QUESTIONS REGARDING ZAC THE
WINCOR POKE.
HER A CO PRESCRIBING OF NALOXONE
IS REQUIRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
FOURTEEN CLARIFIES THAT.
THE CLUB THE ALSO CLARIFIES THE
COOK PRESCRIPTIONS NOT REQUIRED --
WHEN THE DRUGS IN QUESTION A
PRESCRIBED ORDERED OR
ADMINISTERED -- UNDER DIRECT
CARE IN THE INPATIENT SETTING --
Và C PRESCRIBING REQUIREMENTS
TRULY INTENDED FOR OUTPATIENT
CARE WHEN A PATIENT LEAVES A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR CLINIC OR
SURGERY CENTER WITH A
PRESCRIPTION TO BE FILLED FOR AN
OPIOID OR A BENZODIAZEPINE.
AND FINALLY CONCERNS BEEN
EXPRESSED THE BILL DOES NOT
EXAMPLE SCRUBBERS PROVIDING
HOSPICE CARE TO PATIENTS.
WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION A LOCK
SO MAYBE CONTRA INDICATED AB
SEVEN FOURTEEN PROVIDE SUCH AN
EXEMPTION?
PROVIDES CLARITY SPECIFIC
SPECIFICITY THE REQUIREMENTS AND
ENSURES THAT THE APPROPRIATE
EXEMPTIONS FOR CORPORATE
SCRIBING OR IN PLACE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MRS IN
SUPPORT -- CALLOUS AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME AND
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI I'M JENNIFER SUMMERS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
MEDICAL BOARD RECEIVED MANY
CALLS FROM AND POSITIONS IN
SETTINGS WERE PHYSICIANS
PRACTICE AFTER AB TWENTY SIX
SEVEN SIXTY WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
THE BORDERS BEEN BOARD STAFF IS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT STAFF WERE LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR
INTRODUCING THIS CLEAN UP BILL --
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS MANY OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED AND TO THE
BOARD ALTHOUGH THE BOARD DOESN'T
HAVE A POSITIONAL POSITION AT
THIS TIME THE BAR WILL BE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE BOARD
SUPPORT IT WOULD AND AS A SEX ME
THANK YOU.
ZACHARY CORPORAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MARIA SPUR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MAKING ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT THE AUTHOR IS
DONE ON THIS BUT THERE ARE FEW
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS.
THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING ON FOR
INSTANCE THE BILL DOES NOT COVER.
NURSE PRACTITIONERS OR BECAUSE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS WHO ORDER
AND FURNISH THESE DRUGS AND IT
ALSO DOES NOT EXEMPT PATIENTS
RECEIVING THESE MEDICATIONS
UNDER THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
FORTY CONTINUING THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND WILL
CHANGE OPPOSITION WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE DOCTOR WHAT DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DESERVED
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND CAN
BE SECURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVEN FOURTEEN TO PASS A
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH LOW HI SO I
BRO BRO I BLOOM.
MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN AND WHEN I FONG.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA.
MEDINA HI MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE TING
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
I FONG I THAT BILL HAS TWELVE
VOTES BELIEVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DRIVING AWAY -- A
HOUSEKEEPER AND IT WAS WE HAVE A
TO HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE GET A
MOTION ON CONSENT.
MOTION SECOND BASIC SHAPE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T CONSENT AB SEVEN SIXTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS LOW.
LOW EYEBROW.
I BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU?
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA?
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING. TWELVE
YOUR WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR AFTER MEMBERS AND THEN THE
FINAL HOUSEKEEPING ITEM WHICH IS
THE ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE ROLES.
INCLUDING A MOTION.
MEGYN SECOND CONSECUTIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS.
TO ACCEPTED THE TRY TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY COMMITTEE
ROLES LOW.
LOW EYEBROW BRO I BLOOM.
MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALI.
DALI NOW EGGMAN.
I WENT AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN -- WHEN?
I WHEN I MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
I TING.
LIVE IN -- I WANT KNOWN WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THEN MOVING BACK INTO
FILE ORDER.
WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO.
SOME OF CHAO WELCOME PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SO EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WOULD
STREAMLINING.
THE APPROVAL PROCESS FOR MASSAGE
THERAPY SCHOOLS BY THE
CALIFORNIA THERAPY MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL OR CA ANTI SEAT.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
STUDENTS BE NOTIFIED WHEN THEY
ARE ATTENDING A NON APPROVED
SCHOOL WHICH CAN PUT AT RISK
THEIR ABILITY TO BECOME
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST OR
PRACTITIONERS.
CMT C. IS TASKED WITH.
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC BY
CERTIFYING MASACHIKA
PROFESSIONALS THAT MEET THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
APPROVING MASSAGE PROGRAMS THAT
MEET THE MINIMUM TRAINING AND
CURRICULUM STANDARDS.
UNDER BE IN PICO SECTION FORTY
SIX TWELVE THE CITY HAS THE
DISCRETION TO REQUIRE THAT
MASSAGE THERAPIST.
BE CERTIFIED BY THE CA ANTI SEE
IN ORDER TO PRACTICE WITHIN
THEIR JURISDICTION.
CONSEQUENTLY THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS INCIDENTS WHERE
STUDENTS GRADUATE.
FROM A SIDESHOW THERAPY SCHOOL
THAT IS NOT APPROVED BY CA ANTI
SEEK.
AND AS A RESULT CANNOT BECOME
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST.
DOES SO LEAVING THEM WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE THEIR
PROFESSION.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO FIXED
TIME LINES FOR THE POOL PROCESS
THE ONLY TIME LINE IS A ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY PROCESS. FOR
CA ANTI C. TO APPROVE A SCHOOL
UPON RECEIPT OF ITS COMPLETE
APPLICATION HOWEVER IT OFTEN
TAKES US INDIVIDUALLY LONGER FOR
SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE A FINAL
DECISION -- DUE IN PART TO AN
INCOMPLETE APPLICATION FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT INVESTIGATION
CONDUCTED BY CA ANTI SEE
REGARDING THE SCHOOL'S
OPERATIONS IN FACT -- SOME
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN PENDING
FOR TWO TO THREE YEARS SO
MEANWHILE STUDENTS HOW WHO
ATTENDED THOSE SCHOOLS ARE
UNABLE TO OBTAIN CERTIFICATION.
THIS BILL AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
WOULD PROVIDE BETTER NOTICE TO
STUDENTS WHEN ATTENDING A SCHOOL
NOT APPROVED BY CA ANTI SEE
WHILE ALSO REDUCING THE TIME.
TO OUR TIME PERIOD FOR APPROVING
A A MASSAGE THERAPY SCHOOL OF
RESPECT -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MRS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
I'M WAS THAT THE NAIL CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUCH THAT THE CONSUL --
WE'VE HAD MANY DISCUSSION
CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU AND HE
STAFF BOTH SEN.
SACRAMENTO AND AND HE'S A
DISTRICT OFFICE AND WE AGREE
PRETTY MUCH AND TWO VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS FIRST OF ALL.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS A DISTRICT
PROBABLY HAS SOME OF THE BEST
CHINESE RESTAURANTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND TWO IS THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE TO WRITE LEGISLATION.
THAT -- NOWLEDGE -- HARD
WORKING STUDENTS WHICH IS --
STUDENT WHICH ARE WHO ARE REALLY
DEDICATED TO OBTAINING A
PROFESSION AND ACTING AS
PROFESSIONALS.
AND ALSO RECOGNIZE -- THE GYM AT
SCHOOLS THAT TRULY GIVE
EDUCATION ABOUT THE SAME TIME
GOING AFTER THE BAD APPLES AND
TALK MUCH BETTER APPLES TALKING
BUT STUDENTS.
WHO ARE REALLY NOT ATTENDING
CLASSES REALLY NOT -- OBTAINING
EDUCATION OR JUST A TRYING TO
GET THEM SET ACIDIFICATION
FRAUDULENTLY AND ALSO OFF TO
SCHOOL STATE ENGAGE IN FRAUD.
AND AND NOTHING BUT A SUBTERFUGE --
FOR DIPLOMA MILLS THE STILLER AN
ITEM ON THE BILL AS IS A
TECHNICAL ISSUE THERE THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON WAYS DALY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE WAYS
THAT THE COMMITTEE STUFF.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES WHICH IN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SOME OF WHICH I DO WISH TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
THINK WE ARE MUCH.
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
D'ARTAGNAN SORRY. TO THE LEFT
SOMETIMES.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY THE
THROUGH A MEMBER THAT THIS I
THINK IS THE FIRST -- MASSAGE
BILL I'VE HEARD THAT HASN'T HAD
LINES OF OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT
SO YOU SEEM TO BE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT AND HERE SO
CONGRATULATIONS ON ON TRYING TO
WORK ON SOMETHING WITHOUT.
THAT THE THE HOLES MEAN JAM TO
PEOPLE COME TO TALK ABOUT MYSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION
THE SECOND TWENTY SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE TWO MOTIONS
TO PASS LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BRO I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND THEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA?
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
THAT HAS TWELVE ULTIMATELY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SUMMER
CHAO WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE BY SUMMER
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAY SHINE THIS
DOES ENJOY A TO PASS ON BOTH
SIDES I'LL WITH THE IMMENSE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY.
QUESTION I'VE OUT MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND DO
YOU ARE PRESENTING WITH YOU
COMMITTEE IMMENSE IS THAT
CORRECT CORRECT WONDERFUL ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR I MEAN
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE.
THE MEMBER MENTIONED MISTER
CHAIR JUST IF I COULD JUST HAVE
ONE WITNESS INTRODUCED HERSELF
AND IF THAT BE OKAY YES OF
COURSE A LEVER.
HELLO C<c.cyan> EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR</c>
OF MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH NOW.
AND WHERE THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR YOUR
PROPERTY SO THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
PLEASE TAKE A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB EIGHT FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW I
BROKE BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
DON'T AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA?
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR UP TO
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB FIVE EIGHT EIGHT BY
SOMEONE OR CHEN -- DISCO IN
ORDER TO THEN THE SUMMER CHEN
THERE'S FILE EVER FIVE AND ALSO
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN IF YOU COULD PLEASE BEGIN
WITH.
A FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND AGAIN THIS
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
WITH THE SUGGEST IMMENSE PLEASE
PROVE PRESENT METAREDDIT.
OUR STUDY FRESCO.
HE WAS FOR YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW AND
MEMBERS OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
HENRY BRZEZINSKI.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN -- HAS
SPONSORED THE BILL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL CALIFORNIA WELL FIRST
SO SEE XIN AS WELL.
ON THIS WAS A CALIFORNIA WELFARE
ASSOCIATION IS A RECENT MERGER
BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
CONTROL DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE STATE HUMANE ASSOCIATION
OUR STATE WHY GROUP REPRESENTS
BOTH GOVERNMENTAL AND NON PROFIT
ANIMAL SERVICES AGENCIES -- SAID
RECURRENCES THAT THERE'S THIRTY
THOUSAND DOG BITES OCCURRING
EVERY YEAR THIS IS NOT BODE WELL
FOR COMMUNITY SAFETY SPECIALLY
BONE WILL POPULATIONS.
ANIMAL SHELTERS WANT TO BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION NOT PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
THAT MIND RESPONSIBLE SHELTERS
DO COMPLETE BEHAVIORAL
EVALUATIONS OF DOGS THE CURRENT
BEST PRACTICE OF SHELTERS IS TO
FULLY DISCLOSE ANY PRIOR BITE
INFORMATION CONCERNING BEHAVIORS.
WE WANT TO BE ASSURED THAT ALL
SHELTERS AND RESCUE GROUPS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FULL
DISCLOSURE.
SHELTER DOGS BITING THE CHILD
MAKES FOR NEGATIVE FEELINGS
TOWARDS ALL SHELTERS REDUCE
VISITS TO THESE FACILITIES AND
REDUCED OPTIONS AND POTENTIAL
LIABILITY.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THE COMMITTEE -- VOTE IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL -- TO H. SHELTERS
AND FIND THE RIGHT FOREVER HOMES
FOR DOGS AWAITING ADOPTION
THANKS SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
TO TESTIFY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN NONE ANY WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
HAD THIS BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE
BRO.
BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
HI CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
I MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE DOLLY
[inaudible]
DALY AYE.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I MOVE ON TO FILE I
REMEMBER NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE AT THIS AGAIN
ENJOYS TO SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
OUT PLEASE FEEL FREE 2% WHENEVER
READY THANK YOU MISTER I
RESPECTFULLY US WHEN I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TRANSMETAL SO SEE ATION SPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
RECOGNIZING YOUR TIME WHAT'S
MAKE MYSELF AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
ALL THE WORD MAN WITH AT T.
SECURITY SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ALSO
HERE IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
WONDERFUL DID YOU FLY ALL THE
WAY FROM FLORIDA TO COME HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND PRESENT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHICH MEANS BEGIN
SUPPORT FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE SEE NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- THERE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM COULD
BE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE RUSSIAN IS
TO PASS LOW.
LOW AYE BRO BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
MY CHEN I'D CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
TING.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NUMBER ONE TO FOLLOW AND A
MEMBER TEN WHICH IS AB NINE
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OR WHEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHEN THIS
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES TO
HELP PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
CHAIR -- EIGHTY NINE SEVEN THREE
CLARIFIES THAT COMPLIANCE WITH
THE US PHARMACOPEIA NATIONAL
FORMULARY AS A BASELINE LEVEL OF
COMPLIANCE FOR THE COMPOUNDING
OF DRUG PREPARATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS AND SODA GRAN FROM
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OPEN AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
FOR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
AS A CONSUMER PROTECTION AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE REGULATION
OF ALL AREAS OF PHARMACY
PRACTICE THE BOARD BELIEVES THAT
BOTH CONSUMERS AND THE REGULATE
A PUBLIC ARE BEST SERVED WHEN
LICENSEES.
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PRACTICE EXPECTATIONS THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR COMMITTEE ASK
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I REQUEST
YOU HAVE.
I JIM GROSS ABOUT CARDINAL
HEALTH -- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT WILL
PROVIDE STANDARDIZATION WITH
RESPECT TO THE REGULATION OF OUR
NUCLEAR PHARMACIES WE ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY.
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOOKS LIKE
THERE ARE NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND IT IS SEVEN ONE OR
WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE --
RESPECTFULLY ASK RECKLESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TWENTY SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW AYE BRO BRO I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN HI -- AND I MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
WHEN I OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN BOTH WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS THERE IS
JUST ONE ADDITIONAL AUTHOR THAT
WE'RE WAITING FOR AND WILL
PROVIDE THAT ALTHOUGH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE WHILE
WE GO THROUGH SOME ADDITIONAL.
DEALS WE DID NOT HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED YET FOR ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE SO -- WE WILL GO
THEN TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO
TWO H. WILL NEED A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND.
THIS IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B..
TWO TWO EIGHT THERE'S BEEN A OR
A MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW LOW AYE
BRO FOR I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHAN I CHILL
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY DALY AYE
EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
SO THE AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM INTO THIS IS A
BEFORE.
TWENTY THIS BILL A MOTION AND A
SECOND TWENTY SIX TODAY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOR TWENTY MOTION AS YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW AYE BRO BRO I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY DALY AYE
EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING I'VE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB. FOR
SEVENTY SIX TWENTY SIX STRAIGHT
THIS EMOTIONAL SECTOR AND A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX MOTIONS
TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW LOW
AYE BRO.
FROM NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DALI.
DALI NOW EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA?
BUT IN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE. THIRTEEN TWO TWO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THEN -- FINALLY
LET'S JUST GO THROUGH THE REST
OF THE BILLS AND FOLLOW ORDER TO
SEE IF ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISH TO ADD ON SO AGAIN -- BOGO
TEND TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS AB.
FOR NINETY EIGHT AB FOR NINETY
EIGHT TO PASS TO COMMITTEE ON
VETERANS AFFAIRS CHILL
[inaudible]
FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MULLIN.
I AM UP OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE. FOURTEEN ZERO IS THE
ROLE OF AND PERHAPS MEMBERS --
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AB FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
OPERATIONS CHILL.
GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE [inaudible] FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN VOTES BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN TRAPS MEMBERS FILE UNDER
NUMBER SIX AB.
SEVEN ONE FOUR AB SEVEN ONE FOUR
TWO PASSED COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
JILL.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MULLIN MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE TING.
TING AYE. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR US
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS AB.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE I SOME EVER
CHAU.
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE MOTION AS
THE PAST YOU [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE. FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR US TO
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE AB EIGHT FORTY
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AN
EDITOR PREPARATIONS CHILL.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE. FIFTEEN VOTES BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR AFTER MEMBERS.
FIVE NINE OR TEN A. B..
NINE SEVENTY THREE GIVE ME NINE
SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS [inaudible]
TO GLORIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE. FIFTEEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN TRAP
SUMMERS AND THEN FINALLY THEN
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE CHAD.
AB TWENTY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS
[inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP BY GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TWO I TWO I AT MCCARTY
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING I SIXTEEN WHAT'S IT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE JUST WAITING FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL AUTHOR -- WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS MEETING IN THREE
MINUTES IF THE AUTHOR DOESN'T
ARRIVE AND IN THE MEANTIME WHAT
AT FOR ADDITIONAL IT IS.
THE MEMBERS TO ADD ON SO.
LET'S THE ACTUALLY GO THEN TO
ALSO THE ITEMS -- FOR
HOUSEKEEPING WHICH IS THIS FIRST
ONE WHICH IS CONSENT.
AND COMEY SECTOR.
THIS IS AGAIN FOR CONSENT
MEMBERS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS
CHILL. TO AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE. SIXTY VOTES ON THE
CONSENT AND THEN AND THEN TO
COMEDIC ROLES.
MOTION IS A VOTE TO ADOPT TWENTY
ROLLS.
201-922-0222 I GLORIA.
SEN GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
YES. FIFTEEN ABOUT -- FIFTEEN TO
ONE THAT IS ON COMMITTEE RULES
AND THEN GOING BACK AND FILE
ORDER. FOR ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- THEN GO ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE WHICH IS AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS CHILL. TWO I GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE. SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE AND REMEMBER.
TO AB.
FOR TWENTY AB FOR TWENTY MOTIONS
YOU PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
TO AYE GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
SIXTEEN OUT.
I WOULD JUST OF GO TO OUR FINAL
AUTHOR THIS IS JOHN SIR PLEASE
FEEL FREE 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
WE KNOW WHERE YOU WERE.
OKAY SORRY THANK YOU I GOT STUCK
THERE TALKING ABOUT SKINNING
DOGS.
I'LL MAKE IT SHORT.
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE CLARIFIES A
COOK A CLEAR TIME FRAME FOR
WHICH CANNABIS BUSINESSES NEED
TO COMPLY WITH LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT REQUIREMENTS.
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT THIS
AGREEMENT BETWEEN A BUSINESS
ANALYST BURDEN IS ATION DEPT.
PRESCRIBE THE OBLIGATIONS OF
EACH PARTY THESE AGREEMENTS TEND
TO INCLUDE MUTUAL MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL PROVISIONS TO PROTECT
BUSINESSES AND FACILITATE.
THE ABILITY FOR EMPLOYEES TO
ORGANIZE CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THAT CAN IS BUSINESSES WITH
TWENTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES ENTER A
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT WITH THE
UNION.
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE REQUIRED
BUSINESSES WITH TWENTY EMPLOYEES
ARE MORE. TO ENTER LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OR
EMPLOYING THE TWENTIETH.
OUR PLAN THE PLANO TWENTIETH
EMPLOYEE THIS MEASURE WILL
PREVENT ARBITRARY ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST CANNABIS BUSINESSES AND
WILL PROVIDE EMPLOYEES WITH
CLARITY ON WHEN AN EMPLOYER IS
FAILING TO COMPLY WITH THIS LAW.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IS JAZZY GRAY WALL FROM
UFC W. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR GUY VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT JACQUI GAY WELL HERE WITH
YOUR C. W. WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE I'M HERE TO HAPPY
I HAVE HERE TO HAT AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MAP BROUGHT
WITH THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WHICH IS SPEECH AT THIS TIME
SEEN KNOWN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TINA QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION A SECOND.
THE JUDGE WHAT YOU WISH TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MUSIC DAY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASS COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT LOW.
WELL I BROWN [inaudible]
BRUNO BLOOM.
HI JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
FONG NOW GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
THE DEAN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE NOW.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE ACTING
[inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
YEAH.
11-3 WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
TRAPS MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THEN THE ELBOW WILL GO IN ORDER
TO THEN -- BACK.
FOR AN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SO --
LET'S START WITH THE TO
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
FIRST ONE IS. FOR CONSENT.
HI MY CONSENT EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE.
EIGHTEEN NO.
IT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR UP
TO MEMBERS.
THEN ON TO ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
I HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW. 1-622- WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THEN.
GOING FILE ORDER FILE I REMEMBER
ONE AB.
TWO TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS GLORIA AYE
GLORIA AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE. EIGHT ZERO FINE
UNDER MEMBER TO AV.
FOR TWENTY MOTIONS YOU PAST
APPROPRIATIONS GLORIA AYE GLORIA
AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE.
IT.
TWO ZERO LEAVE THE ROAD TRIP TO
MARS I DID FILING NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX
MOTIONS DISASTER PREPARATIONS
CHILL. TWO I GLORIA I'M GOING
AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
FOLLOW NUMBER. FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY EIGHT MOTIONS TO PASS A
COMMITTEE ON VETERANS AFFAIRS
CHILL. TO AYE FONG.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE AROUND THE AYE.
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL. TO AYE
GLORIA VOTING KOREAN NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE I WILL BE I FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB IS.
SEVEN ONE FOUR MOTIONS THE PAST
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH CHILL. TO
AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE.
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AB.
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED YOU. TO AYE GLORIA.
GORE I HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAU.
CHIU AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TEN AB.
NINE SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS YOU
PASTOR PREPARATIONS CHILL. TO I
GLORIA.
I HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS.
GLORIA AYE AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
AND THEN FINAL LET'S SEE I FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB.
TWELVE NINETY ONE MUCH IS THE
BEST COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
DOLLY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE.
OKAY -- WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OF WILL GO THROUGH A FUN AND ONE
MORE TIME TO LEAVE IT WILL
DOUBLE TO IT IN -- ONE
ADDITIONAL MINUTE BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST ONE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBER.
SO JUST WAIT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WE GENERALLY.
THIS CHANGES WHAT WILL BE A VERY
VERY.
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE THIS IN
MCCARTY PLEASE ADD ME AS I A FOR
ALL THE MEASURES THAT ARE ON
CALL.
AND SIMPLY MISS MCCARTY ON THE
ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE RULES AND
CONSENT CALENDAR.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY AND WHAT IT GO IN.
ORDER AGAIN AS AS WELL.
AND A FIRST ITEM THEN LOOK AS IF
AS THE FINAL ROUND OF WHICH IS.
ON CONSENT TO LET'S GO TO
CONSENT.
ON MY HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. SIX
THREE AND CONCERT.
CONSENT ITEM EIGHTY SOME SIXTEEN
MOTIONS DO PASSED HOLDEN.
PULLED AYE.
KATE THE CONTENT IS BEEN DUBBED
IT.
AND THEN -- NOW TO THE DOCTRINE
OF COMMITTEE RULES.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE. EIGHTEEN TO
TO THE UC BERKELEY RULES ARE
ADOPTED AND THEN WE WILL GO IN
FILE ITEM ORDER FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB TWO TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLD I KATE [inaudible]
TO IF.
YOU'RE ALREADY HERE MISTER
GIBSON -- NO NEED FOR YOU AT THE
THAT WAS THAT TWENTY TWO ZERO
AND THE BILL IS OUT FOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IN THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A BEFORE.
TWENTY WHICH IS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
TWENTY ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
FOR SEVENTY SIX MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE. SIXTY THREE THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB. EIGHT FOUR NINETY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT MOTIONS
YOU PASSED A COMMITTEE ON
VETERANS AFFAIRS HOLDEN.
PULLED AYE.
IN NINETEEN OH THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
[inaudible]
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT CHEN.
QUESTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HOLDEN I
NINETEEN OH THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE AND NUMBER SIX AB.
SEVEN ONE FOUR BUT SINCE YOU
ASKED ME ON HEALTH HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE. TWENTY ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE IN NUMBER EIGHT AB.
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE. TWENTY ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN
HOLDEN I TWENTY ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
PHONE NUMBER.
TEN EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY THREE
MOTIONS YOU PASTOR PREPARATIONS
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE. TWENTY ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TEN I HAVE ELEVEN FALLEN OR
ELEVEN A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE OCEANS THE
PASS HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE. TWENTY
ZERO THE BILL IS NOW AND THEN
FILE I'M NUMBER TWELVE AB.
TWELVE NINETY ONE MOTIONS THE
PAST COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
MPLOYMENT.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
FIFTY THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY WE ARE ADJOURNED